okay sherry's off today your most
accurate weather now forecast our camera
looking across
at the strip it's been bouncing around a
little bit did you hear the wind
whipping during the overnight hours
not quite as windy as yesterday when
there were gusts over 40 miles an hour
now 65 is the official temperature out
at mccarran let's see what's happening
where you are
we have a 61 down at mountains edge and
roads ranch
meantime still hanging on to 70 around
the strip
but everybody is still seeing those
winds between 10
and 20 miles an hour we expect the winds
to slowly die down during the day today
but moms dads grandma grandpa
getting the kids ready for school keep
that wind in mind a sweater or a jacket
is probably going to be a good idea
because we will be in the low to mid 60s
in some neighborhoods
okay to nevada and beyond they're
slipping into the teens up there in ely
some snow flurries and that's
particularly the case up in northern
utah down into the southwest cedar city
good morning you're at 35.
kingman arizona 54. how about death
valley county you're at 76 trombones
down below 60 over the hump and from
sandy valley hanging on to a 60 and
again those wins are the big story
for the numbers well we're done with
three
days in a row with the afternoon high
exactly at
91. that's not going to happen today we
may not even reach 80 but we'll sure try
cooler temps for sure there's the system
we just got rid of
for your family and friends across the
nation that's one of the big storm
systems
maybe some rain snow showers over the
u.p of michigan and some rain
lingering over the new england states
here is your eight day forecast so after
the
near 80 today we will bounce into the
mid 80s and stay there pretty much
the rest of the week maybe a cloud or
two here and there there's that nice
game at t-mobile arena on friday the
one o'clock game on sunday afternoon
we're keeping an eye on some potential
wind returning over the weekend but for
now we'll leave it off the
eight day forecast